he had when he played the long game so  maybe d4 maybe catalan like pushing the  g pawn and then i think getting the  bishop if uh  if it's the game yeah  yeah i think you're right uh maybe not  necessarily starting with the d-pawn but  that type of setup right white can go  for so many different different move  orders towards the catalan opening and  uh i would be slightly surprised if we  see magnus open with his king's pawn  just because he was neutralized there  easily in the world championship match  um i think yeah magnus he he will  surprise jan no matter what he'll  surprise us no matter what jan is maybe  more predictable with his opening  choices